in setting out to write the various
movies that you've written do you look
at it in terms of the demographic that
you're going for hey if I were 18 this
is what would scare me this is what
would shock well we've had the the
benefit of having a love for for horror
films and watching the ones that pander
versus the ones that cater and maybe
surpassed the expectation and so the
that kind of general it's so easy to hit
the middle and it's always an
unsatisfying result like the diminishing
return of a sequel expectation is this
endless middle that just keeps coming
more and more and more until the buck
stop and then all right they'll throw an
ending on there and see how it goes but
we had a chance to make a movie here too
we had a chance to shoot on film we had
a chance to work with the entire crew
from the walking dead in between season
one and two and stretch every dollar
into a hundred okay well let's make this
movie like is the last one will ever be
able to make this will be our tombstone
and we're going to do it with bloody
satisfaction who cares about what
anybody wants but what we need to
survive right now and be the best that
was the best way to go about it that's
what kind of charged our DNA to be a
different sequel to be a confident
departure from the first movie and exist
on its own and that that was that was
endlessly fulfilling from a creative
standpoint from a production standpoint
and now i think the the audience that we
cooks into the dark get that effect as
well that we get to all stand on a bull
neck when we see this movie and that
feels good a lot of movies that do you
know clearly Oh are trying to go for
pg-13 or whatever some movies don't need
their their pg-13 they're fine like the
paranormal movies don't need to be are
at all because it's just it's that tie
it's a supernatural horror movie about
ghosts and it's fine you know that
doesn't need to be but other ones that
are in this in the sub-genre that this
one is what's more like Sarah killer
type thing right it just feels lame like
you put pulling punches it's just to hit
rating and that that never seemed to
serve horror fans at all and yeah you
might trick some thirteen year old girl
to go see it but it's instant
disposable and so we didn't particularly
ought to do that we made enough movies
like we know this is our tenth to
produce movie we that we don't really
need to do that and so we didn't we had
the best of both worlds we were able to
lie to an audience in the first act and
set up this teen movie that was he could
just see it by the numbers sassy best
friend uh he's the cute brother he has a
crush on the lane gal oh boy but if she
would just catch that dirty boyfriend
cheating uh and then WHAM get rid of it
all we don't like mini movies either
here the adults are going to step over
all the pieces of these kids and go how
the hell did we find this guy what are
we gonna do to him that was nice to take
action movie characters and drop them
into a horror movie villain scenario we
because we took everybody skill set away
and handed it right to a guy was zero
tolerance because we were given that any
given the note of like you know what if
we had a younger sexier guys and then if
I with roller eyes really come on like
well what uh you know how long do they
live bar and we don't carry my like okay
well yours the opening yeah man it's
like we wanted like the horror fans who
had awareness of what's in the genre to
walk in and go I'm Hannah just oh ok I
could follow these idiots for the next
you know 90 minutes but we know they're
dead Oh way we will have been there all
and now you've shaken the rules to the
core yeah anybody can get it
you